A JUDGE HAS GIVEN DONALD TRUMP'S
LEGAL TEAM UNTIL 3:00 P.M. TO
RESPOND TO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT'S MOTION TO UNSEAL
THE SEARCH WARRANT AND PROPERTY
RECEIPT FROM THE MAR-A-LAGO
SEARCH.
OVERNIGHT, TRUMP POSTED ON HIS
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM THAT HE
WOULD NOT OPPOSE THE RELEASE OF
THE DOCUMENTS.
IN FACT, HE SAYS, QUOTE, HE
WOULD ENCOURAGE THEIR IMMEDIATE
RELEASE.
NOW, THAT'S WHAT HE SAYS.
BUT REMEMBER, HE'S HAD THE
DOCUMENTS SINCE MONDAY.
AND HE COULD HAVE RELEASED THEM
AT ANY POINT HIMSELF.
HE STILL COULD.
HE DOESN'T HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL
3:00 P.M.
HE COULD RELEASE THEM RIGHT NOW.
ALSO, REMEMBER, WHAT HE SAID IN
THE PAST ABOUT WANTING TO
RELEASE HIS TAX RETURNS.
AND ULTIMATELY NOT DOING IT.
WE'LL SEE.
AS OF NOW, HIS ATTORNEY SAYS IT
DOESN'T APPEAR THEY WILL OBJECT
TO THE RELEASE.
>> SO ATTORNEY GENERAL MERRICK
GARLAND SAYS HE PERSONALLY
APPROVED THE DECISION TO SEEK A
SEARCH WARRANT FOR TRUMP'S
MAR-A-LAGO HOME.
WHAT MAY BE THE MOST
EXTRAORDINARY OF ALL THE
DEVELOPMENTS IS THIS NEW
REPORTING BY "THE WASHINGTON
POST" THAT SAYS CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS RELATING TO NUCLEAR
WEAPONS WERE AMONG THE ITEMS FBI
AGENTS SOUGHT IN A SEARCH OF
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FLORIDA
RESIDENCE ON MONDAY, ACCORDING
TO PEOPLE FAMILIAR WITH THE
INVESTIGATION.
THAT COULD TURN THE CONCERN OVER
THESE DOCUMENTS UP TO 11.
IT'S REALLY A GAME CHANGER WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WHAT COULD
HAVE BEEN IN THESE PAPERS.
>> NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
JOINING US NOW IS FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL ALBERTO
GONZALEZ, THE DEAN OF BELMONT
UNIVERSITY COLLEGE OF LAW AND
ATTORNEY GENERAL, I WANT TO
START WITH THE WASHINGTON POST
REPORTING.
I'LL READ ARE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS RELATING TO NUCLEAR
WEAPON.
HOW SERIOUS WOULD IT BE IF THOSE
DOCUMENTS WERE AT MAR-A-LAGO?
>> WELL, IT WOULD BE EXTREMELY
SERIOUS.
I THINK IT WOULD CERTAINLY
FORFORM
LEGITIMATE BASIS FOR ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO APPROVE UNPRECEDENTED
SEARCH OF THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
ESTATE.
THIS IS INFORMATION AT THE
HIGHEST ORDER THAT'S IMPORTANT
TO KEEP CLASSIFIED FOR THE
NATIONAL SECURITY OF OUR COUNTRY
AND I THINK WOULD JUSTIFY, IF
TRUE, AGAIN.
AS I THINK SOME OF THE REPORTING
INDICATES, THESE KIND OF
DOCUMENTS MAY HAVE BEEN SEARCHED
FOR.
WE DON'T KNOW WHETHER OR NOT
THERE WERE ANY THAT WERE FOUND
IN THE POSSESSION OF FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> ACCORDING TO "THE WASHINGTON
POST" REPORTING, WE DON'T KNOW
WHY THEY THOUGHT THAT DOCUMENTS
RELATING TO NUCLEAR WEAPONS WERE
THERE AND WE DON'T KNOW IF THEY
TOOK DOCUMENTS RELATED TO
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
WE ONLY KNOW THEY SOUGHT THEM.
SO IN THEORY, WHY WOULD THE FBI
OR JUSTICE DEPARTMENT NOT WANT
THEM, NOT WANT THIS TYPE OF
DOCUMENT AT MAR-A-LAGO?
>> WELL, BECAUSE, AS I SAID -- I
JUST SAID THIS IS INFORMATION
THAT IS CLASSIFIED AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL.
IT'S INFORMATION THAT ENEMIES OF
THIS COUNTRY WOULD WANT TO GET
THEIR HANDS ON.
AND OBVIOUSLY IT'S INFORMATION
THAT WE WANT TO PROTECT TO THE
GREATEST EXTENT POSSIBLE.
IT'S INFORMATION THAT IS STORED
AND SECURED LOCATIONS AND
GOVERNMENT BUILDINGS AROUND THIS
COUNTRY.
AND YOU CAN'T HAVE THESE KIND OF
DOCUMENTS TO SLING AROUND IN THE
HOME OF PRIVATE INDIVIDUAL.
SO, THAT'S WHY THEY -- IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE CONTROL OF
THESE KIND OF DOCUMENTS.
>> MERRICK GARLAND YESTERDAY,
THE CURRENT ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
THE UNITED STATES, IT'S A JOB
THAT YOU HAD, HE CAME OUT WITH
THIS STATEMENT.
AND I THINK IT WAS A SURPRISE TO
SOME PEOPLE SAYING THAT THEY HAD
FILED A MOTION TO RELEASE THE
SEARCH WARRANT.
HE SAID DONALD TRUMP COULD
OBJECT IF HE WANTS, BUT HE MADE
THAT ANNOUNCEMENT.
WHAT DID YOU THINK OF THAT MOVE
FROM THE ATTORNEY GENERAL?
>> WELL, I THINK IT WAS -- I
THINK IT WAS A GOOD MOVE.
I THINK THAT FIRST OF ALL, I
THINK COMING OUT AND SAYING
SOMETHING WAS IMPORTANT.
IT WAS IMPORTANT TO CONFIRM TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT HE
AUTHORIZED THE SEARCH.
THIS WASN'T A DECISION MADE BY
SOME UNDERLING.
I THINK HIS COMMENTS ABOUT THE
INTEGRITY OF THE DEPARTMENT I
THINK THOSE WERE STATEMENTS THAT
NEEDED TO BE SAID.
HE NEEDED TO SHOW HIS PEOPLE IN
THE BUILDING THAT HE WAS FOR
THEM AND WOULD PROTECT THEIR
INTEGRITY.
SO I THINK IT WAS IMPORTANT.
ALSO, THE STATEMENT ABOUT
UNSEALING -- REQUEST FOR
UNSEALING THE DOCUMENTS I THINK
WAS MADE BASED UPON HIS JUDGMENT
THAT UNSEALING THE DOCUMENTS
WOULD NOT COMPROMISE THE
INTEGRITY OF THE INVESTIGATION
AND ALSO IT PROVIDED PROTECTION
TO THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
YOU WANT TO PROTECT THE RIGHTS
OF INDIVIDUALS IN CONNECTION
WITH AN INVESTIGATION.
SO GIVING HIM THE ABILITY TO
OBJECT OR TO APPROVE THE RELEASE
OF THE INFORMATION I THINK WAS A
WISE DECISION.
>> SO, OVERNIGHT DONALD TRUMP
SAID THAT HE WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
RELEASE OF THESE DOCUMENTS.
HE HAS HAD THEM SINCE MONDAY,
THOUGH, AND HE COULD HAVE
RELEASED THEM AT ANY TIME.
WHAT DOES IT TELL YOU THAT HE
H
HASN'T RELEASED THEM TO THIS
POINT?
>> AGAIN, THIS WOULD BE PURE
SPECULATION IN TERMS OF WHY HE
HASN'T RELEASED THEM.
PERHAPS HE SIMPLY HAD NOT HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO THINK ABOUT ALL
THE REPERCUSSIONS OF RELEASING
THE DOCUMENTS.
THE CYNICS WOULD SAY THIS GIVES
HIM -- NOT RELEASING THE
DOCUMENTS GIVES HIM TIME TO
LAMBASTE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND USE THE SITUATION
FOR POLITICAL PURPOSES.
BUT THERE COULD BE REASONS WHY
HE DECIDED NOT TO RELEASE IT.
HIS LAWYERS MAY NOT HAVE HAD A
CHANCE TO DEVELOP A STRATEGY TO
MAKE A RECOMMENDATION TO HIM.
SO THERE MAY BE LEGITIMATE
REASONS WHY HE WOULDN'T RELEASE
THE INFORMATION.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, EVEN IF
THE INFORMATION IS RELEASED,
THERE MAY BE NOTHING IN THERE
THAT REALLY HARMS THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
ON THE OTHER HAND, THERE MAY BE
STUFF THERE THAT MAY ARGUABLY
HARM THE FORMER PRESIDENT, BUT
HE MAY MAKE THE CLAIM THAT,
WELL, I THINK THIS WAS PLANTED
BY THE FBI.
SO, WE'LL HAVE TO WAIT AND JUST
SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> YEAH, WE WILL.
VERY WELL MAY SEE 3:04 THIS
AFTERNOON WHAT THE DISCUSSION
HAS BEEN.
I DO WANT TO ASK YOU BEFORE WE
LET YOU GO, A MAN IN OHIO IS
DEAD.
A MAN THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT SAYS
TRIED TO ENTER AN -- ARMED MAN
TRIED TO ENTER THE FBI FIELD
OFFICE IN CINCINNATI.
SOMEONE WITH THIS MAN'S NAME OR
AN ACCOUNT ON TRUMP'S SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORM IN THIS MAN'S
NAME, WAS POSTING THE TYPE OF
THING THAT WAS SUGGESTING THAT
HE THOUGHT VIOLENCE WAS
NECESSARY IN THE WAKE OF THE
SEARCH AT MAR-A-LAGO.
AND ORE INCENDIARY TYPE THINGS
IN THIS ACCOUNT.
WHAT CONCERNS DOES THIS RAISE
FOR YOU?
>> I HAVE VERY SERIOUS CONCERNS
ABOUT THE VIOLENCE THAT EXISTS
IN THIS COUNTRY, THE TRIBALISM
IN OUR POLITICS.
YOU KNOW, PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK OUT
AGAINST THE VIOLENCE ON JANUARY
6th.
HE COULD HAVE SAID SOMETHING.
HE COULD HAVE DEMANDED OR
CERTAINLY ENCOURAGED PEOPLE
THERE AT THE CAPITOL TO LEAVE
PEACEFULLY.
HERE IS ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY FOR
DONALD TRUMP TO SAY SOMETHING
ABOUT -- AGAINST VIOLENCE.
AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE HIM TO DO
THAT.
WE HAVE TOO MUCH VIOLENCE IN
THIS COUNTRY TODAY BASED UPON
DIFFERENCES OF VALUES,
DIFFERENCES OF OPINION.
WE NEED MORE CIVILITY.
QUITE FRANKLY LESS DISCOURSE AND
WE NEED LEADERSHIP AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL, NOT ONLY FROM THE
FORMER PRESIDENT, BUT LEADERS IN
CONGRESS, WE NEED REPUBLICANS
SPEAKING OUT, AS WELL AS
DEMOCRATS, AGAINST VIOLENCE.
WE MAY HAVE DISAGREEMENTS, BUT
WE CAN'T HAVE VIOLENCE.
>> FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL
ALBERTO GGONZALEZ, I DO
APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US THIS
MORNING.
>> THANKS, JOHN.
>> LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL NOW.
ELIE HONIG, KARA SCANNELL AND
ALSO WITH US JESSICA ROTH AS
WELL AS GREG EERY WITH THE FBI
FOR MORE THAN 20 YEARS AROUND
CURRENTLY THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND ANALYSIS AT
THE ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE.
I DO WANT TO START WITH YOU,
ELIOT.
THESE DOCUMENTS THAT WE MAY OR
MAY NOT SEE AT 3:00 P.M. OR
CLOSE TO 3:00 P.M., WHAT MIGHT
THEY SHOW?
WHAT MIGHT THEY NOT SHOW?
>> OKAY.
SO WE'RE NOT GOING TO LEARN
EVERYTHING TODAY.
I DON'T THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
BE DISPOSITIVE ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER WHERE YOU CAN LOOK AT
THOSE DOCUMENTS AND SAY
CONCLUSIVELY, A HA DONALD TRUMP
WAS RIGHT.
A HA DOJ IS RIGHT.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO SEE THE
AFFIDAVIT, THE LONG NARRATIVE
THAT PROSECUTORS PUT TOGETHER,
HERE IS OUR EVIDENCE, THAT IS
THE PROBABLE CAUSE.
DONALD TRUMP DOES NOT HAVE THAT.
THE THREE THINGS THAT WE ARE
GOING TO POTENTIALLY LEARN TODAY
ARE THIS, FIRST OF ALL, HOW DID
THE FBI AND DOJ DESCRIBE THE
PREMISES THEY WERE GOING TO
SEARCH WITHIN MAR-A-LAGO.
THAT COULD BE INTERESTING.
HOW SPECIFIC AS TO CERTAIN
ROOMS, THE BASEMENT, THE SAFE.
NUMBER TWO, WHAT TYPES OF
EVIDENCE WERE THEY LOOKING FOR
AND WHAT TYPES OF EVIDENCE DID
THEY SEIZE?
AGAIN, LEVELS OF SPECIFICITY AND
GENERALITY VARY QUITE A BIT.
I HAVE SEEN THAT DESCRIBED AS
ALL DOCUMENTS, ALL LAPTOPS BUT
SEEN IT BROKEN DOWN IN MUCH MORE
SPECIFICITY.
NUMBER THREE AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY, WHAT POTENTIAL
CRIMES DID PROSECUTORS BELIEVE
THEY HAD PROBABLE CAUSE TO SHOW
WERE COMMITTED.
THAT LIKELY WILL BE IN THE
DOCUMENTS IF THEY COME OUT.
I'M GOING TO LOOK RIGHT TO THAT
BECAUSE THAT WILL GIVE US A
SENSE OF WHERE ARE PROSECUTORS
ON THIS?
WHAT CRIMES DO THEY THINK?
DID A JUDGE SIGN OFF ON MAY HAVE
BEEN COMMITTED.